What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are playing table tennis battleship!
First one to pop all five balloons wins
Let's go!
This is the first one
So scary
Last time I lost to Otto
But I'm smarter this time
I've got it all worked out
What's that sound?
Are there any spare balloons?
Because I think I might...
What happened there Emil?
Nothing!
So annoying!
Next one you blow up Emil you are not allowed to replace
Hi Otto!
This is the golden one
He will never pop this one
Keep your eyes on this one
Because this one will make it through the whole game
This is the golden one
He will never pop this one
Alright so there was a bit of an accident with the balloon
But we are back on track
Okay I hope we are finally ready!
Good luck Emil!
Good luck Miikka!
This is always so nervous!
This is yeah!
Am I even gonna hit the table?
No, you don't hit the table!
Two!
Double shot!
It sounded like a double pop
No!
Not even close Emil!
I think it was quite close!
How am I not hitting them?
That was actually really close!
Was it?
Are you bluffing or?
I don't know!
That was really close!
How does he know where my balls are?
3-0!
I actually think it's somewhere...
It's a long one maybe!
Now I'll start popping them
Or not!
Emil do you even have any balls over
there?
I might have put some under the table!
Yes!
I got one!
I had to give him one
The square to Emil's right
Right on the edge
I didn't hit it, did I?
I feel that it's somewhere there
But I haven't just hit it yet
I still think it's in this corner
Or no, this corner
Short!
Who is gonna hit it first?
Yes!
Okay you touched it
That was the second time Emil touched that ball
Really?
Second time?
Why didn't I get the pop from the
first one already?
Okay you got that one Emil!
Thanks
3-1!
One more to go!
I'm pretty sure it has to be a short one
And I think it's on the right side too
Maybe middle short?
He is may be onto something
No, it's not under the table Emil
It's gotta be long far
No!
What happened there Emil?
Nothing!
Did it touch the balloon?
Ah okay... well now I know where it is!
Not even close Emil!
Okay now you hit it!
That was a jackpot
It definitely was a jackpot!
Yeah... okay
Okay now we are both down to the last balloon
So it's a perfect time for you guys to hit subscribe!
It's down to the final balloon Emil!
No!
Yes!
Come on!
Finally I found it!
It was somewhere here, right?
It was this one
Oh it was this one?
It was that one yeah
Okay hope you guys enjoyed this balloon battle!
Next time it will be me against Otto
The winners play against each other!
Until next time!